greetings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happened now is brought to you
and we'd love to introduce Stan's socks
that old pack of white gym socks your
mom used to buy you at the grocery store
is now a thing of the past
Stan's has changed the game they brought
art and good design to what used to be a
boring old white stinky dead sock now
when you show your ankle you're also
showing off what makes you special
whatever you're into they got Star Wars
socks
harley-davidson socks they even have
Grateful Dead inspired sucks they got
little ankle socks it's not just cool
colors and patterns Stan says everything
from running socks ankle socks hiking
socks and premium socks that you can
wear at the office do me a favor right
now the church family Stan's has a great
offer go to Stan's calm right now
slash shirt CH you are CH and you'll get
a free pair of socks with any purchase
that's right a free pair of Stan's
stocks socks with any purchase that
Stan's comm slash Church and you get
your free pair of socks this offer is
only available for a limited time so get
your socks now at Stan's com slash
Church because if they're not Stan's
that just a pair of socks the church is
also brought to you by 23andme listen
it's time we're living in an incredible
time you don't mean I'm an only child I
lost my parents when I was pretty young
so I didn't get the chance to ask some
of the questions about their health
their parents or what kind of genes I'm
dealing bit with but with 23andme I just
spit in the tube bang and I found out a
ton about myself and the people where I
came from listen I think it's a great
experience I find out I'm like American
Indian I'm not really a Seminole I gotta
be like a piano Indian or one of those
Indians I got a little African brother
me like my parents come from Spain that
type of stuff
23andme reports do not
diagnose diseases have described you
overall likelihood of developing any
disease 23andme test selected genetic
variants only visit 23andme comm slash
church @c h you are CH for important
test information and order your health
and ancestry kit a at 23andme dot-com /
church that's 23andme
coms last Church and you can meet your
genes in 125 plus personalized genetic
report that's 23andme comm / Church find
out who we are Lee kick this
[ __ ] meal everybody didn't have
to do that there was at one point in the
mid 70s towards late 70 77 78 the kinks
did it with Superman I want to be like
Superman the stones did it with some
girls and the other one they did that
they ain't a bag of dicks in [ __ ]
Europe kiss kiss kiss was like yeah you
had to put a beat out that was danceable
yeah something that you could dance
still we don't yeah and I could just
imagine the going in to kiss and people
like those bands and saying that like
your number one hit has to have
something that they can play at the
close they actually thought the future
of rock and roll was gonna be infused
with lots of disco so kiss Paul Stanley
and Jean they made a decision because
after that was 1978 and then in 79 they
put out dynasty which had I was made for
lovin you sure know something are very
very disco yeah and then they had an out
that whole album after that was super
disco as well kiss on mass so they
thought that the trend was they thought
they had to make a movie was a
calculated move we gotta go more disco
than rock we got it while everyone else
was getting heavier cuz in 78 van Halen
busted out and they weren't trying to do
disco and then Ozzy came out with you
know blizzard of Oz and
some bands went heavier some bands chose
to go more disco and kiss chose disco
for a bit and they went you know they
went south and just completely turned
into like a joke I had not seen this
about three weeks ago I got all you know
when you come on the Comedy Store you
have a bag out of bulls and reefer and
[ __ ]
all that [ __ ] from speedwall and chef
max train oh yeah they just absolutely
hook it okay so sometimes you have that
bottled water here in the car
so some I'll okay and I'm popping [ __ ]
Brian I'm popping whatever they gave me
a bull's eye mad at all by the time I
get over the dry land which is once you
bit Ventura yeah that's what starts
getting little tingles and ship I'm all
round I'm 3/4 there if it hits me too
quick I just stopped at yum yum donuts
and you got a bran muffin to come that
[ __ ] Savage
couple nights ago put on if this is love
by Van Halen it's gonna say live from
Seattle when MTV first came out this was
one of the first videos in their
rotation I love you remember it me and
my wife would just talk a great song and
I just put it on the second side of one
of my there would mean streets on it the
one with Unchained - fair warning
fair warning is one of my all-time
favorite great album you know not
Oakland yeah oh so you had a hope
whatever you see is he singing with the
bottle of Jack damn it is it is like
when you watch this you go you know what
this was the best van Halen ever was I
mean I know they made a lot more money
with Sammy Hagar and the I was in San
Diego but if you ever have a chance put
on Van Halen so this is love from
wherever the [ __ ] six 1281 open call 81
this was actually a video that was on
MTV every hour on the hour
me and Joe Rogan met him at the Comedy
Store dude like 2006 or something like
that and all he wanted to do is talk
about like chicks the chicks he got on
the road and he just couldn't stop
talking about the good old times he said
that he would give his roadies a
backstage passes like a stack of them
what and they would put their initials
on him and their goal was to go out and
find the hottest chicks in the crowd
give him the passes and if he ended up
having sex with them and there he'll
give 200 bucks to initial was on that
pass isn't that brilliant
for someone who's single you know what I
mean it's a brilliant idea
oh [ __ ] who doesn't want to go backstage
you know is that some of them we went
with their boyfriend oh yeah oh yeah
yeah so they're like I'm just gonna go
backstage just to say just for a little
bit and he said he would see the
boyfriend it's just like waiting for
them up in the stands Brian they just
[ __ ] spent their milk money another
ticket for those days there's no
conversation you just blow him he makes
Harvey Weinstein look like a [ __ ]
preach it yeah that guy he just takes
his dick out yeah just get on the bus
they suck it they give him a kiss there
was no pictures no there he imagined it
there was no proof you imagine all the
meters that would come out of like David
Lee Roth ran for like government
official some it's really interesting
that you said that one the twisted
system movie came out Rudy Sarzo called
when they were talking he goes what do
you think of it you know I liked it I
enjoy it I told everybody thought it was
a goof but I enjoy it at least I enjoyed
it because they're only gonna get better
now
these stories are only gonna get better
yeah they gonna make him better and
better and better and they're gonna be
[ __ ] phenomenal but he goes you know
what's really crazy if the me to
movement he goes this was beyond me -
yeah that music industry all those years
they were beyond me - yeah there was no
conversation there was no pictures
there's no not that
it was your word against me and my
[ __ ] roadies yeah I went back there
and they they they rate what do you tell
them about you want back that we
attendees out you know it's [ __ ]
crazy those girls don't even didn't even
raise their hands in the seventies they
never raised their hands not that I was
a part of it I saw it but I heard him we
wore her we bumped into different people
that have talked about Pauly Shore Pauly
sure used to get his dick sucked like
nothing you know I'm Pauly Shore in 1990
when he came into your town warlock
remember warlock warlock was his little
story yeah great guy a warlock from the
storm oh yeah he won't like was the guy
with the passes okay that was his
partner three blondes I saw its face I
would yeah I want to do it you want to
go it takes a certain type of animal
yeah to go up to women and go can I talk
to you for a second now you're uh mr.
Rothstein would you like to go bite then
say hello no cameras a lot leave the
phone outside yeah thanks for certain
animals to go in there and it takes a
certain woman to think she's gonna go in
there I mean in a perfect world you're
gonna go in there they don't want
nothing from me but it's not a perfect
world
they either gonna pass you around there
was an episode long on last week where
the band was huge then they went down
over the years and they were playing
like bars now yeah most bands but the
guy was the pyrotech guy made the Pyro's
too strong and lit the bar on fire and
eleven people died and they checked that
stuck up from was it groupie she said I
couldn't have been him because I was in
the van giving him a head and all the
other people were like no you weren't
you were standing next to us but that
was just and they even said to me this
usually happen to you
and he goes it happens all the time what
is somebody thinking that they'll just
go into somebody's tour bus suck their
dick and walk out I mean isn't it like a
point probably there's a comic that I I
see everyone tomorrow as a story about I
forget
when it was but one of them and like to
her it was a good success like a point
of pride I mean I think that's sort of
the difference with Harvey Weinstein is
like out from what I heard these
musicians weren't offering anything it's
just they were the know there was a big
musician like no get to suck my Jimmy
Page is there you're going back to the
suck his dick he's not gonna give you at
all lessons I think I'll play ukulele
put you on an album up with John now you
know there was no there was no nothing
you going back to the meet the band
yeah pretty hard and me too rock stars
that's that's a hard one that was a hard
one of those days even now to come out
and go 30 years ago what happened 30
years ago what happened who was no room
you know who's gonna remember where
their drugs involved no we didn't you
know and that that's what you're
thinking God knows that you were doing
you know there's so many [ __ ] angles
that's why it's so hard to hold a rape
case even if it's textbook it's so
important there's so hard to get the
conviction because they destroy the
woman on the witness - you don't want to
go through that it's a [ __ ] nightmare
but if you what are you gonna say that
in 1979 you want to see Ted Mero Smith
and and Steven Tyler [ __ ] in the ass
against your will
where you gonna go with that well you
gonna go with that yeah first of all
you're 62 DNA has left your ass four
times over
Lodi shot your ass let DNA I'm wrong
their DNA stays there forever but you
know I think I don't [ __ ] know I have
no idea you know she goes on 23andme
that would be great you know what [ __ ]
[ __ ] ain't like that no more though
because I went I went to see corn and I
was backstage and there's everyone's
wives there with their kids they let
their kids on say that corns plan and
their kids are running on stage and
backstage it's it's nothing like you
would imagine you think like oh [ __ ]
they're partying in the you know there's
all these chicks and everyone's getting
naked
not at all completely
well the only listen if you wanted to
Allison change room today there's no
booze oh yeah this Canada Dry ginger ale
please take your places we're talking
about tomorrow to go play golf
yeah what happens what do you think was
like this
Soundgarden and Allison's changed
restaurant rule in 1994 a little
different you have any idea what Allison
chains [ __ ] dressing room was like
you didn't go in there that micro smoke
none of the micro smoke the vape pen
what were they doing never doing heroin
before the show you think I on stage
there's a maintenance amount and when
you become a junkie you know I knew
junkies that I had to go to work in the
morning and they had a maintenance
somehow who their eyes get pinned what
they don't know I can still function and
they could still function at times
you'll see their eyes going but at least
it's like when I smoke dope in the
morning I don't smoke dope to get sonic
I smoked dope just to wake me up on my
coffee get the day you little hit just a
little three buckets you know [ __ ] okay
I get the wing going I guess soon as you
wake up no I'm not that much of that
what time do you usually smoke worse all
right look first time let's say I get up
at 7:00 okay when I walk out and make up
a cup of coffee a pee make a cup of
coffee and then my bodyguard attacks me
okay so I can't do that
so I gotta sit next to her watching some
bad cartoon just god-awful card what is
she like that's the she's been into the
descendents don't know what that is one
two and three the chick with the purple
hair and the other one with the blue
hair is it a movie it's a movie to see
but you want to sit there and stab your
neck on the same descendants yeah like
the other day she tricked me she goes
daddy the one who wants descendants too
and all right it's it's a change I get
out there put your little headset on
your blood podcast I sit next straight
you know you gotta give me the attention
they deserve
and then after 10 minutes ago didn't I
see this last night and she goes I like
the I wanted to watch this bad yeah yeah
Toy Story the latest one full ah
brilliant Toy Story flowers and blinds
brilliant I took 2 edibles and put the
3d glasses on The Lion King no no good
Toy Story 4 was right in the middle of a
Toy Story for that big earthquake hit we
were at the theater at the arc like
going oh damn a lot of people were
running out of theater we went into the
exit you know the little door threshold
the legs were waiting that and dude it
was going for like a minute and then
when it was over like I wanted to see
the [ __ ] ending decide to ask Draco
and my wife like you guys want to stay
cuz I'm down there like ok so we went
back so I get up I thought once I start
talking I'm alright then I got on the
computer I see email me look at my
schedule for the day what time is this 8
9 so now we got to be talking about
correlate okay for 45 minutes after I
get up I go to my back bathroom I open
up the door caste yard yep and I take a
[ __ ] and I take bong hits while I [ __ ]
so the call pushes out to [ __ ] without
somebody trying ok nobody dies little
[ __ ] stroke you you always coughing
smut always know but when you when you
go the [ __ ] flies out of your ass okay
don't think you're dealing with joy
bananas you know I invent different
things every week I got a different
adventure every week so yeah when you
hit that bomb head it's a [ __ ] bonnet
at 7:45 in the morning with this other
half these we all like you smoking a
cigarette that first at first that's
first you feel that first six inches
just come on it's like a baby's head
when it comes out of the snatch and just
a head SATs at for a little while and
then I pack another ball with six inches
up and when I hit that sec well you just
feel it coming out just hanging you
leave it hanging
oh yeah he's an acrobat I pushed a rest
on the second cloth I wipe
and I [ __ ] done I really lost a pound
now I'm I I don't drink any more coffee
and start drinking cold water now to get
my body gone yeah that's it and then
once I take a shower and eat breakfast
and stuff whatever depending where I'm
going I'll do a few buckets before I
[ __ ] leave
but you just had the bong cats you don't
have another one damn you can't walk on
one leg yeah yeah you're a gangster man
cuz I really I don't smoke as much weed
as I used to it Oh like I like I like
taking time off no I can't smoke the
weed I used to anymore because I have
mercy
yeah I gotta pay more attention to
places I go to yeah you can't go in
there smelling like [ __ ] Jolly
lebombo like a head shop you know you
gotta be a little [ __ ] decent so I
gotta go somewhere where I'm gonna be
there for watch it pop - edibles yeah
I'll have a bowl I can't do any edibles
man how about Missy no there's so much
[ __ ] gone out of my life you know that
that my main focus in life is peace I
just want peace and harmony I don't want
any [ __ ] in my life so I I avoid
[ __ ]
I like the plague I don't I don't want
to deal with anything I just want peace
quiet I want to be with my family
teach jiu-jitsu I do comedy just purely
for fun I sprinkle that in my life as
long as it doesn't affect anything boom
I put it in and I'm good I don't need
anything else that's it what new
conspiracy theories do we have to
discuss today oh man even gave me the
flatter you gave me the jimmy angel
stole his wife off the balcony I didn't
know that wasn't me that made no I think
it was you somebody called must have
been Sam careful they through Jimmy it
could have been Sam I'm throwing Jimmy
Hendrix's girlfriend off the balcony
I'm just really entertained by following
DC and what's going on I'm super
entertained about it that's that's my
real that's Game of Thrones times 100
when you find out how the what the real
game of Thrones is like
it's [ __ ] fascinating I'm down with
every day I spent two hours catching up
on what has happened that day but
because you're getting from nineteen
ninety percent of what you're getting
from the mainstream media
is [ __ ] so where do you where do you
read the stuff then you got a well it's
my process of elimination
you know like 90% of the mainstream
media is not the truth so you know if
you're searching for the truth
I like the truth I don't like being
[ __ ] I like I like knowing how
they're trying to [ __ ] with my brain so
by process of elimination you know okay
you just turn on CNN and go okay this is
all [ __ ] so let's try to find the
truth it's not that so there's a lot of
independent independent media outlets I
like I like listening to x-22 report sgt
report those two right there they'll
give you the good [ __ ] right there it's
true reporting all on YouTube all great
stuff my ex 22 that's the best that's
like when those shootings happened last
week they weren't a so you know the
people that are following what's going
on we're expecting it they're like oh
man they're gonna they need something to
clog up the new cycles cuz a lot of [ __ ]
is going down right now at the D class
man people are going down with it the
between the D class and Epstein's island
man a lot of people in trouble big
powerful people so anytime something
like that happens
they always it wouldn't surprise me if
you know those shootings were there was
more people involved than we're being
told because they're multiple witnesses
saying there was multiple shooters and
that's pretty common in these cases like
there's multiple shooters like people
are like they're saying there was two or
three shooters they keep saying that but
the official story what you're getting
on the mainstream news is that that was
one shooter crazy dude you know trying
to blame it on Trump the dude in Dayton
Ohio was a leftist he was all about
Elizabeth Warren if they're keeping
quiet about that because you know
everybody wants Trump
how you know they're trying to bury him
and why they trying to bury him why is
the lies 90% of the [ __ ] mainstream
media trying to bury what's really going
on and then you look into it that's
what's that's the fascinating thing it's
like why are they trying to bury Trump
you know they try to pin him like CNN
try to pin him they try to turn all
Mexicans against Donald Trump by Donald
Trump was talking about ms-13 and was
saying they're animals or criminals we
got to get him out
so then CNN goes look what Trump said
about Mexicans so they cut out the ms-13
part and just said there are animals
they're criminals and we got to get him
out what does that tell you what is that
they're trying to frame him and then
look what happened with rush inclusion
you know what's going down the deep
glass is about not only wasn't and isn't
Trump a Russian spy is they try to frame
him with that that's what the D class
that's what they're trying to bury
that's what that's where they're clogged
and the new cycles it wouldn't surprise
me if there was you know like they take
a schizophrenic paranoid crazy kid and
fill them up with all this crazy [ __ ]
that they need to need to do to drag him
to a certain place put a gun in his hand
and then have professionals do a bunch
of shooting professionals get the [ __ ]
out of the way and they just they got
their patsy that wouldn't shock me stuff
like that wouldn't shock me you know
there's some you know William Cooper is
no William Cooper wrote the book behold
the pale horse and he was a work for the
office of Navy intelligence and he
figured out he was a whistleblower and
he figured out a lot of [ __ ] he wrote
like that book and he wrote this in the
book real quick
this is 1991 he wrote this
the government encouraged the
manufacture and importation of military
firearms for criminals to use this is
intended to foster a feeling of
insecurity which would lead the American
people to voluntarily disarm themselves
by passing laws against firearms using
drugs and hypnosis on mental patients in
a process called Orion the CIA
inoculated the desire in these people to
open fire on schools and thus inflame
the anti-gun Lobby
this plan is well underway and so far is
working perfectly the middle class is
begging the government to do away with
the Second Amendment wrote that in 1991
it's what they do to get some crazy kid
fill them up with all this propaganda
anybody they want to blame it if they
want to blame it on Castro they can take
a crazy guy make him like a Castro
fanatic get him all crazy they can't
they can't trust him to kill anybody cuz
he's just crazy who knows what he's
gonna do they just have to put him in
the scene of the crime they get some
professionals shoot up the place they're
all saying multiple shooters witnesses
are saying there was multiple shooters
are dressed in black they look like
professionals
San Bernardino same thing they're all
that's what people are saying I don't
know that's what the witnesses are
saying people that were there so it
wouldn't shock me if those shootings
they did happen people died people got
their lives ripped apart and destroyed
but wouldn't you want to find out like
who exactly did it if you found out
you're one of you like your mom got
murdered and then the cops told you was
it was uh you know Joe but then other
people kept telling dude it was Lee
wouldn't you want to find out don't you
want to find out how it really went down
instead of going don't say the cops said
it was Joe don't disrespect me like that
but God says dude got a look in the lead
yeah so is it you know to me but people
get angry when you're saying did what
the official story is saying man there's
witnesses saying there was multiple
shooters don't doesn't that don't you
know how it really went down there's
been 240 sound shootings you know
something's not right something is not
adding all when you look at all those
[ __ ] on earth they all happen right at a
time where people are going down some
people are gonna testify all of them all
of them
there's a list think but this isn't
supposed to happen this is supposed to
this person supposed to test the fire
boom shooting this person supposed to
testify boom shooting what they do
they're clogged they don't even like in
all this others gun control talk it's
almost like they don't care really that
much about you know passing gun control
laws it's not really about that it's
about arguing about that taking up your
time everyone has a certain amount of
time to look into [ __ ] so if they make
it seems like they're if you know it
seems like they it's sloppy on purpose
so all the conspiracy theories could
talk about and spend a lot of time
making podcasts about and listen listen
that's what they want it's like talk
about it yeah sure they want gun control
and sure they're gonna piggyback on top
of that you know while we're at it we
might as well add a couple more gun
control laws or whatever but it's not
about that it's about clogging up the
news cycle think about the [ __ ] that's
going down right now the proof the Trump
got framed for Russia is coming out
that's coming out and people can bust it
they're going down for it
boom shootings happen tool clogs up the
news cycles everyone's talking about gun
control gun rides and you know you know
and and you know while we're on gun
rights you know there's nobody nobody
that can convince me that it makes sense
for me to give up my guns that I have at
my house just in case that alarm goes
off and someone breaks in me and my wife
got plans we've got the plan we talked
about it that alarm goes off someone's
[ __ ] getting shot right so some crazy
kid hopped up on pills go shoots up a
mall does it make sense that I give up
my guns because he did that that does
not make any sense that I have to
my guns because there's some crazy
people out there shooting people you
were
I need my guns even more now so there's
no way anybody will ever convince me
that it makes sense for me to give up my
guns because some crazy kids shot up a
mall like it makes zero so how does that
make any sense that is Mike any sense
how would you start I mean obviously all
the the gun violence are these [ __ ]
rifles these high-powered rifles with
[ __ ] automatic clips and 250 [ __ ]
rounds and all this [ __ ]
how do we start to put a to chip away at
this if I had him if I had a bazooka you
wouldn't have to worry about me
it's like you know a teepee 80,000
people eighty ninety thousand people a
year die from car accidents how can
we're not trying to get rid of cars and
what about the eight hundred thousand
kids that go missing every year no one
gives a [ __ ] what about that what about
all that little all the kids all the the
kids that are getting raped on that
epstein island where's where's your hash
tag me too right there why is it only
hash tag me two of its some [ __ ]
out-of-work aging actress who said that
some [ __ ] producer
grabbed her tits in 1972 oh me too that
let me do that lets me do that but what
about all these kids eight hundred
thousand that's an FBI statistic 800,000
to a million kids go missing and then
sure people go like them they don't want
to go but most of those are like the
dads stealing the kids away in the
divorce and all that I'm like okay okay
eight hundred thousand let's just say
seven hundred and fifty thousand are
those cases are like you know but a
domestic dispute may steal the kid or
whatever if it was twenty thousand kids
a year to get kidnapped and nobody gives
a [ __ ]
no one's don't meet you in that [ __ ] no
one cares you know what you would you
tell them if you tell him uh I bet if
you told I talked about this on Sam's
podcast too
bet if I told you if we just said hey
[ __ ] Epstein's murdering puppies on
that [ __ ] at all the vegans [ __ ]
not stop murdering but we gotta save the
puppies we gotta save the puppies but
kids nobody gets this [ __ ] about kids so
shut the [ __ ] up about your [ __ ] gun
logic and all that [ __ ]
you have no logic you're worried about
machine guns you weren't about machine
guns come on man if you're worried about
machine guns then I need a machine gun
you turn you're trying to take away
machine guns [ __ ] that means you need
machine gun why are you trying to take
away machine guns when I'm walking down
the block I don't know what my
statistics are of a car running a red
light and hitting me I know we have a
lot of [ __ ] and accidents and car
accidents and the kids I don't know what
the [ __ ] going out with kids I don't
know who takes them they take off to
Mexico I don't [ __ ] know what I do
know is that I got a look-alike is it
signed now when I sit in the movie
theater I got if I go to a Garlic
Festival I gotta look around
fences and [ __ ] to see what's going on
with my wife and kid the same way you do
because when you watch this [ __ ] now we
can't go to Walmart you know you have a
guy in Dayton shot people of one of the
morning and night well they weren't
bar-hopping
you know this concerns me to the point
where whatever the [ __ ] it is something
has to be done I mean what about Chicago
Chicago gets that every weekend no one's
doing [ __ ] about that Chicago Puerto
Rico I mean listen it's it's it's well
we're trying to figure out he was just
out of control but what what if what if
there what if they are being set up by
some nefarious group I think that listen
the Chicago thing is the [ __ ] Street
beefs
and some guy gets shot with a 22 some
guys at a bar or something like that
what concerns me is is if you go to
Vegas to see Nine Inch Nails we
Danny you believe that if you ban
machine guns that that's not gonna
happen
no no I think that'll just it just
creates higher demand and people will
pay more that I believe it's not gonna
change she'll know where would start I
don't know how I I don't know look at
every day we look oh my god oh my god
last night I had a little Burbank for
something you know let's start at 7:00
[ __ ] 30 and I made a right on this
[ __ ] Street right by the Nissan place
on unfuckin Lankershim okay that
McDonald's on the corner and that gas
station or am/pm on the corner there
right versa
Riverside Riverside or whatever did you
see what it I was at the light and I
looked and I saw a 6-inch rat go from
the [ __ ] side the weeds down to a
homeless tent that whole street is
filled with homeless people what's on my
ride down you know you pass CBS and the
ha [ __ ] the black haircut in place
and I'm sitting there going where do you
start with the homeless people when we
start with the gun is that it I don't
know taking away the machine guns gonna
stop shooting what I'm [ __ ] telling
you is you know we start we got your
[ __ ] I know we started Wow
by not ignoring the fact that witnesses
said there were multiple shooters and
get to the bottom of that maybe we'll
find answers to ask how it really starts
so when El Paso there's witnesses the
multiple suitors when many of the
shootings there's they there's witnesses
saying there was multiple shooters the
one in Parkland there's a teacher a
teacher saying I opened the door and
then I there I saw 20 feet away from me
the killer he was in armored helmet he
looked like a SWAT member shooting she
says this like wait a minute it was a
kid that did it he wasn't a some big-ass
dude and SWAT gear you know not that the
SWAT team did it I met my gear like you
know he had like.he armor body armor and
a helmet and a [ __ ] gun
we need to get to the bottom of that
instead of ignoring that like why are we
ignoring that that's the problem
no why are we ignoring all the the
mental pills that in the end they're the
crazy pills that all these kids are on
why are we ignoring that i'ma tell you
something and if you remember this kid
from El Paso the gift in the Garlic
Festival and the kid that chopped a
movie theater during Batman or whatever
the [ __ ] you remember that [ __ ] police
mug shots
didn't look like they were high on
something
yeah like [ __ ] gone right yeah you
know that's saying that this kid no pass
no I ain't saying much that he's just
sitting there kind of like in shock you
know that he doesn't know what happened
the dude from the the Colorado shooting
the movie there the Batman right not
that one
that guy's yeah members picture you is
all [ __ ] but you may ignore that they
ignore the pharmaceutical side of it you
know they ignore that but so who they
want to go out like maybe that'll make
it different easy attack that taking
away guns like gonna make a difference
but is it the government behind it or is
it like I'm the question that's the
question that's what we need to look
into what what is going on here
why are coincidentally these shootings
happening when big [ __ ] is about the pop
and the government we need to look into
that like a like a detective would look
into that okay case solved it's over
what was what was happening when Vegas
went down that was a big trial going on
[Music]
he's got all this [ __ ] this fall yeah so
like here's my question for you guys
because I I'm a little bit more on the
liberal side with guns I've never had
guns they I don't really want one but I
spent six months in Israel where and
every mall every McDonald's everything
they have army with metal detectors
because we probably can't get rid of
guns but do you what do you think people
would be okay with that with having
metal detectors and having retired army
people everywhere like I'm October 2nd
2017 the Benghazi mastermind Abu
khattala
goes on trial that same night the
Las Vegas Massacre happened I don't know
maybe there's a coincidence I mean I can
go on there's a whole list of all the
shootings and what happened like I mean
I don't know maybe it's not true but I
don't know there's like the Vegas
shooting there's a lot of like weird
[ __ ] about that they know what's on
tomorrow that's gone they just it's gone
let that go
why look at all the people that died why
they let them 58 people why they let
that go
why they bury that I like I said I'm not
here yeah true realizing it or making
fun of I understand we got a look into
you I wanna know what really went down
who who was really behind I wanna kill
it really went down and how to stop this
you have a child I have a child someday
leaves I would be married to have a
child people will listen to the show
have a child
yeah and the last thing you need is to
be at a movie theater and a skating rink
and one of these retards pulls up this I
mean is it smart to I mean we all want a
solution wouldn't one of the steps to
the solution be like let's find out what
really happened why are people saying
there were multiple shooters that look
like they were dressed like with body
armor I'd that's that's some pretty
important [ __ ] right there that's
important [ __ ] if that was multiple
shooters uh it's pretty important
but wouldn't wooden wall Mart have
cameras exactly let's see that ban that
let's see that let's see that do you
think they'll release it do they usually
so do they release any of the footage
for you think Mandalay Bay has any
cameras anyone yeah they should in the
room though
you don't need the cameras in the rooms
to figure out the [ __ ] is going on I'm
except for the rooms there's cameras
everywhere right right wouldn't you be
able to see like dudes like lugging all
that [ __ ] none of that got released
right I don't know maybe it's illegal to
release it skank stir [ __ ] going on man
was gangster sure going on a lot of
people dying you know and a lot of clues
Latta witness testimony being ignored
and covered up and buried I
- why scary [ __ ] scary [ __ ] I just
wanted to stop I just wanted you know
the Escalade in New York a motorcycle
backfired on Times Square people ran
like it was Godzilla people ran down the
street like it was a [ __ ] Godzilla
with did I tell you what happened me
yesterday what I got a doctor's office
I'm minding my own business I pull in my
park
I walked I call the office I show him my
license I pay the deductible I [ __ ]
go and they waved me I talked to the
lady she takes my blood pressure I sit
down lady comes back she goes it's gonna
be about 10 20 minutes we're running
behind all right no worries I got
nowhere to be
next you know [ __ ] alarm goes off me
being the size I am I just get up I
don't even want to get up cuz I know
it's probably [ __ ] and they come on
there's a fire in the building
everybody's gotta leave talking like
Pete I saw people you know because this
[ __ ] gets into your psyche now this
stuff gets into your psyche and now you
can't live normally you cannot you walk
around this people who or any of these
people who watched the news every night
and believed every word to the t-mobile
85 per se be 5% and I'm not putting
those people down they really don't know
a life outside that news you know I'm
not saying I'm gonna fire Bay the cap on
this more than anybody else but when I
watch Eyewitness News and they go
tornado 75 million in danger and also
they show Iowa and they show call it the
corn farms I don't see nobody's standing
out there all right how are they in
danger
you know ABC they use big words the
uproar about blah blah blah what uproar
you talking about I talked to 200 people
day nobody's meant
so it's like they're selling you a bill
of goods
that's not even has nothing to do you
gotta keep you they gotta keep you watch
grade they got to keep the fear level
high big otherwise why would you need
them I really want to look into shark
attacks every year I'm really [ __ ]
shark attacks happen every year the last
two weeks they talk about a shark attack
every day
it's what and they show you they have
ten fingers but every day they show you
the same three [ __ ] fingers well I
mean to me it's the same thing as like
so comedy clubs they're essentially bars
some of them are care if they put on a
good show but most of them they only
care if they get people there so they
can sell drinks that's their business TV
news they sell advertising they just
want your watch they don't I mean that's
kind of why I guess maybe the YouTube
thing would be a good place to go
because even newspapers they sell
advertising that's not they don't really
care what the news is they all they care
is if they sell advertising that's one
way of looking at it another way of
looking at it is you know radio
newspapers TV since day one of their
inception have the purpose internet the
purpose the purpose of the internet was
to program you and sir surveil everybody
easier from day one that's the whole
purpose of it the whole purpose of radio
wasn't like oh I wish we could figure
out a way to transport you know music
through the airwaves and and entertain
people we really need to entertain
people no it's like how how people are
running countries and empires all
they're concerned about is keeping their
power and keep and controlling the
masses minds cuz the masses have the
power they knew the truth they have the
power so it's all about controlling
Minds so the radio was like ooh this is
gonna be a great way to control their
mods and then TV oh we got a better way
to
their minds and then the internet
they've been working on the internet for
a long time it was a way it's not for
entertainment it's a way to control our
minds because if they can't control our
minds they have no power so that's what
it's all about we are living in a
[ __ ] dream all this [ __ ] that we grew
up with think about like the movie like
Jaws I I will not go in the goddamn
ocean because of Jaws you know what that
does to you
you watched jaws it gets [ __ ] people
afraid of the goddamn water you know
what I'm so goddamn afraid of sharks
then I want my son to watch jaws so he
doesn't do stupid [ __ ] like deep-sea
diving you know what I mean I don't want
him to go to the ocean you know I'll be
scared to [ __ ] death for him you know
so I'm gonna sit him down and make him
watch jaws and me and scare the [ __ ] out
of you know what I mean I'm gonna use
that [ __ ] on him that's some you know
some CIA [ __ ] we don't were in this
world that has been you think you think
over technology technology technology we
are what are you talking about we could
have had free electricity through the
air a hundred years ago
that's what Tesla was doing and they
shut him down he died penniless and
insane once they figured out that he was
like wait a minute
powers gonna be free no no no think
about the one thing that hasn't changed
let's [ __ ] sockets on your wall
that should've been the same since since
you were a kid this is the 40 that [ __ ]
ain't never change they're never gonna
get past that cuz the next step past
that leads to three electricity we can't
have that so we're gonna stay with that
[ __ ] plug in the wall Tesla already
had it figured out Westinghouse are
invested in him and never gonna do it
then they pulled the plug on them no pun
so we're like what about cars cars look
exactly the [ __ ] same as they did in
the [ __ ] 50s yeah the body's a little
different still rubber tires still
engine in the same spot engines better
but it's still extinct you see pictures
of like 1940 or whatever like in
Hollywood you you see like a picture a
picture of the building when it was
being built it's the same [ __ ]
streetlights curbs streets cars the same
[ __ ] houses from 1930
with technology the only thing we got
that bits advances our phones and that's
designed to surveil us this is so they
know exactly what we're at halt as I
said we need to find Joey Diaz he's
right here and he's and we know exactly
what he's thinking and what he's doing
what he's looking at we have all his
[ __ ] every we are afraid of that RFD
chip or whatever that thing is like dude
that's a distraction that Lane trying to
chip nobody they're trying to get you
scared of the chip so you don't even
notice that this is your chip dude this
is your chip RFD chip and can't do this
does everything you can look and sees
your face every day and here's what you
say every word you say it hears and
we're walking around with it that's why
it's advanced because then this is where
the technology needs to be as our
[ __ ] phones so they have tabs on us
but everything else cars same [ __ ]
thing when I was a kid
cars like Oh 32 gallons of the mile
that's pretty badass
guess what today it's still 33 32
gallons a month you'd think it'd be like
150 gallons in my or our miles to the
gallon I'm sorry hundred fifty month
it's still 35 mpg the cars it still
costs the same gas is not that much more
expensive when I was kids like dog $52
it's like four dollars 350 now guessing
going up like regular inflate inflation
cars is the exact same car saying oh
they're a little faster 0-60 and [ __ ]
you know two point three or whatever
anything
the technology is slows [ __ ] the only
thing that's advanced is our [ __ ]
phones that's it
that's it dude you look around it's the
same [ __ ] we're still rolling around and
[ __ ] rubber tires cars Oh doors open
the same [ __ ] way still plugging into
walls we're still plugging our [ __ ] into
walls
solely with technology the one I hear a
lot of Facebook is like part of the
government is that that's totally true
oh oh like Google Facebook Twitter all
of that [ __ ] is all Silicon Valley
Silicon Valley it was all designed to
surveil you all of it all of it is is
it's up for entertainment don't make
they could lose billions of dollars
Google billions youtubers you didn't you
didn't they give a [ __ ] I can care less
yes that's us
surveilling ourselves for them that's
all that is no one's even disputing that
no one's disputing that Google and
Twitter and that why do you think
they're all going after Trump they're
going after Trump because they're all on
the same side let me ask you this Psalm
at home I'm thinking about doing
something my legacy in the world I'm not
funny I'm not athletic I'm smart I like
the army movies so when I go online and
I look up a k47 if they're surveilling
us so much you know why don't we get a
jump on it it's like well I love when
they say that that's a good question I
love when they say today we swore did a
an event in Michigan of another terror
attack by some Arabs well with a sum all
of you know this Arabs only talk to
Arabs okay then I gotta go see we and go
we commit you're a Jew you hate these
white people too they for ability people
hello is half [ __ ] Navajo in the
entrance whatever the [ __ ] they want
Italians and brother what I don't get is
like when they say to you they thought
it you know what they do they think they
hire a [ __ ] Arab out of college and
they make them go into a mosque that's
exactly what they do and what it is is
what's that word when I set you up
there's a word for that
entrapment yeah they're all entrapment
mm-hmm it's all entrapment it's not
legal oh it saves lives it's common
sense when it's true
mob mentality you think about it like
like let's say let's say we're in
another dimension and you're you're
running a country but you're
to be indicted for some serious [ __ ] and
your life is gonna be [ __ ] over dude
some treasonous [ __ ] like the war [ __ ]
right so and someone says someone says
hmm we need a I think if we clog the
news cycles with some [ __ ] I think that
could help what would you say would you
say that was a good idea or not great
that's a great idea okay so how do we do
it that's a good idea
clog the news cycles huh and then I said
I got a suggestion
we need um we need something super
devastating to clog the news cycles it's
got to be super devastating right do you
agree with that okay you agree okay so
we're good
now what's super devastating killing
criminals or killing kids kids kids
we can't just like a bunch of criminals
were killed right it's kind of that
worse would be something that would clog
the news cycles would be devastating
tugging at the hearts and I would kill
kids right right
CIA whistleblowers have said this this
when they when they go to other
countries and they trying to overthrow a
country they blow up schools cuz they
know people are gonna [ __ ] go
blow up school buses that's what CIA
whistleblowers have said that john
stockwell you could watch him on YouTube
he wrote books about it he goes they go
for the worship to cause the most damage
so the people there so there's like the
maximum public outrage right it's a good
idea I'm trying to save you you're about
to go down dude you're gonna get the
death penalty so for you like we want to
clog the new cycles you agree that
that's a good idea and then you agreed
that killing children is probably the
best way right a mass shooting with
children involved right yes or no
sure yes or no yes okay all right so how
do we do that how do we pull that off if
I said what if I suggested let's get
some [ __ ] crazy kid I'll pop we're
going through our database and we look
for the crazy kids that have like a
record of being a schizophrenic right
good idea or no that poster child being
Lee Harvey Oswald I do know so far good
ideas if I say bad idea I'll think of
another
yeah trying to save your life right good
idea right all right so we take me
behind the kid we find him we got a
bunch of kids we got two or three you
know and and do we like you have an
adversary guys trying to take you down
political enemy is it wouldn't it be a
good idea if we made this kid a big fan
of that [ __ ]
cuz he's gonna go down for murder right
and wouldn't it be good if we just like
good idea or bad idea to make him a
soldier for your enemy good idea or bad
idea good idea good idea good idea good
idea it's good great idea right or would
it be a better idea if I made them a fan
of yours
no that's a bad idea bad idea it's gonna
make you look bad this guy murders all
these children family's innocent people
and he's a fan of yours no no no no
that's a bad idea right bad I don't
write bad idea it's a good idea we make
them fan of your political enemy right
so how do we do that we get we have at
my suggestion is just get like like a
dude on him like a handler and we groom
them we get them all into these crazy
schizophrenic and then we get honest on
his social media and we start posting
positive [ __ ] about your enemy and then
he's all down for your enemies down to
kill for your enemy
good idea he's gonna kill for your enemy
right oh [ __ ] yeah perfect right or a
bad idea bad idea good idea it sounds
but then this past weekend they're both
guys no this is a fantasy okay
it's a fantasy so you're got a good idea
right good night great idea so but this
guys [ __ ] crazy how we gonna get him
to them to the mall to shoot people you
don't how are we gonna do what if he
shows up and he just drops the gun
freaks out he's crazy what do we do I
don't [ __ ] know tell me what we're
gonna do here's my idea idea we get some
[ __ ] mob professional hitmen to go in
there spray some [ __ ] cause it's tough
for sure people get killed because if we
give him a gun he and he halfway through
the parking lot who might freak out so
we gotta get him we walk them into the
mall this is
an idea we get professionals to spray
get the [ __ ] out and then we throw them
in cops come grab him good idea or bad
idea it's good idea and do you think I
you think I just made that up
like do you think no one else has made
that out like I just made that up well
like okay how does how do people live
with them is a fantasy world right but
let's say I'm not saying that that's
what happened I'm just saying if you had
to clog up the new cycles to save your
ass wouldn't that be a good idea it'd be
a good idea but I'm just saying like and
maybe there's people who can do it but
how do like if it's CIA or whoever it is
if they're the ones killing kids how are
they like not for killing themselves and
DUI do you believe that there's hired
assassins who don't give a [ __ ] who they
don't know kids
they'll kill anybody going is there
people like that do people like that
maybe people like that don't exist I
don't know if there's people like that
that exist there are hired killers hired
assassins and they get paid million
dollars whatever five hundred thousand
whatever if there's people like that
that exist do you think they need work
yeah they need work and who would they
need work from but shady ass individuals
like maybe the mob maybe the mob got hit
man
they'll kill anybody they don't give a
[ __ ] there's ice cold killers out
they'll kill anybody for money right so
the idea is you you have a whole list of
those mob you're running a country you
have a [ __ ] list the 40 of those
[ __ ] that you need to go out if
you need someone gone you have guys that
are just saying you know just like John
wick or some [ __ ] you know what I mean
maybe they don't exist I'm talking about
this a fantasy world this is a fantasy
world if you had to clog up the news
cycles to bury some [ __ ] coming out on
you
what will we back out what will we
burying this weekend I accomplished a
lot of stuff I'll pass on data what was
getting married I'm not saying I'm just
saying that just coincidence right
uh-oh this is what I'm saying if my mom
got killed or my wife and son got killed
I would want to know how the [ __ ] it
really went down if the cop if the first
official
story said this this is the guy who
killed him I don't say okay [ __ ] that
guy you know he killed my [ __ ] family
but if other people are saying dude
there was multiple [ __ ] I
wouldn't be mad at them for saying there
was multiple [ __ ] and they want
to really get down to who really doubts
it that's fine I'm with you let's
[ __ ] find out who really killed my
son you know what I mean I would be like
you how dare you say that that's so
disrespectful like no thank you
thank you there was multiple shooters
are you sure let's look into it let's
look into it not like get mad it's too
soon you can't say that what the cop
said it was one guy they said the news
said it was one guy why are you saying
that was witnesses said there was
multiple shooters so I would want to
know if my family was killed I would
want to know what the [ __ ] is up with
the multiple shooters what would what
were they covering up for this week by
it a lot of D class going down a lot of
D class a lot of people going down for
framing Trump in the Russian collusion
scandal it's all coming down text
message deep that's what the D class in
here the defies the D class they framed
Trump and that's treasonous and that's
death penalty when you find out all the
players involved scary it's Game of
Thrones [ __ ] dude heads will roll that's
why they're doing this crazy ass [ __ ] in
my opinion the beautiful [ __ ] thing
how's your Jitsu going it's going great
what is that a great view I got killers
all over the world speaking of murder
you know what is the neck CBI the next
my next show is combat jujitsu world's
not this Sunday but next Sunday August
18th in Long Beach you can get your
tickets it inch by inch TV it's the
middleweight world championship combat
jujitsu student it's gangster jiu-jitsu
the most gangster
form of jiu-jitsu there is jiu-jitsu
noogie jiu-jitsu sub-only jiu-jitsu with
palm strikes to the head and body on the
ground and you're on the ground you
could you could well on each other you
get knocked out hell yeah Jesus what
about EBI EBI it will be back end of
2020
or 2021 one then it's coming back where
stabbed my first mission was combat
jujitsu world's EBI was that was a plan
B I wanted to establish a league of
combat jujitsu I couldn't get the rules
I needed or the rules I wanted pass
through the Commission because they
didn't know what it was they just didn't
understand it they wanted it in a cage
and a three three-minute rounds I wanted
it outside of a cage and one ten-minute
round they they just didn't know they
just didn't give it to me the way I
wanted it so I just said [ __ ] I'll
just do I'll just bypass the Commission
and just do sub-only so that's where EB
I came so EB I was like because I
couldn't get combat jujitsu off the
ground and then after about I don't know
was like 9 or 10 EB eyes I went back to
the Commission I said I asked him again
I go can I do
combat jujitsu the way I wanted to you
know a couple years ago when I
approached you guys and they were so
cool they say yes let's do it just do I
go they want to do it not in a cage I
wanted to do it just like because it's a
combat digital world is EBI
it's exactly like EBI with palm strikes
it's there's everything's the same 16
man tournament just like EBI 10-minute
regulation rounds just like EBI all
submissions allowed just like EBI
overtime EBI OT exactly like a EBI exact
same overtime exact same regulation
exact same format 16 man bracket it's
exactly the same as EBI except there's
palm strikes at it so it's more gangster
it's it's a big step towards realism
it's a closer to MMA than ever before
it's it's on its way to MMA which means
it's on it's more realistic than
jiu-jitsu without strikes so it is EBI
with a turbocharger doing great things
in jiu-jitsu world thank you who do you
listen to John Jacqueline Rogan you can
see talking about that [ __ ]
dude he was talking about how they used
to do combat jujitsu back in the 80s and
70s and 80s in Brazil because that's
what we used to do we used to after we
trained with argy for a couple hours
everybody would take off the d top and
then we do jiu-jitsu with palm strikes
so combat jiu-jitsu is actually
old-school Brazilian jiu-jitsu the way
they used to do it back in the day in
Rio de Janeiro Carlson Gracie Jean
Jacques they all did it they called it
bap Aria that means
okay let's basically means combat
jiu-jitsu jiu-jitsu it strikes and so
that I'm basically bringing back old
school jujitsu training more realistic
you know there's a lot of things you can
do or a lot of things you can't do as
well when they're strikes when you're
doing jiu-jitsu so a lot of times you
know who there's um you know I mean
Roger Gracie himself the great Roger
Gracie said 80% of jiu-jitsu is useless
in MMA he said that that's a famous
quote from Roger Gracie he's talking
about gidget's of course 80% of BJJ is
useless in MMA Roger Gracie you know
what I mean to me that's a problem to me
that's a problem with the marshal arm
like I don't want my my jiu-jitsu to be
80% useless in a real fight you know and
MMA is about as close to a real fight as
you can get you know so there's a
problem there so what I've always worked
on is trying to fix that wrong trying to
make your jujitsu training as close and
as real as close to mmm as possible and
as realistic as you can possibly get
without actually doing my brain damage
you know what I mean so that's why the
tenth planet jiu-jitsu style is a clinch
based very clinching base very no space
we don't want space we want to clinch
and you know to a and first and foremost
two fingers yourself from being knocked
out you know if you clench on someone
it's very hard to get knocked down you
know just like in boxing you know when a
guy's getting hurt what does he do he
just clinches and then they got there
Scot a declension the clenching is a
safety technique and most of my jujitsu
is based on clinching staying safe and
moving squeezing clenching smashing
crushing squashing squeezing shocking ha
ha ha yeah yeah where's your next dates
um this Friday I'll be in tin foil hat
comedy me and Sam Tripoli and XG we'll
be in Indianapolis this Friday and then
Saturday we'll be in st. Louis for our
4/20 show so we're doing on like an
afternoon show we did an afternoon show
in Tacoma and to be honest I didn't know
how the [ __ ] it was gonna turn out like
man this could be a disaster Saturday
afternoon show at 4:20 and it was sold
out like holy [ __ ] let's try a couple
more these [ __ ] and see what
happens you know cuz that way they just
get on a late flight and get the [ __ ]
home afterwards so yeah so and then um
we got Bakersfield coming up if you go
on my Instagram at Eddie Bravo 10 P at 1
0 P um I got all my dates up there you
could just click on one of those comedy
Flyers and a Bakersfield coming out San
Francisco coming up Portland Oh The
Improv the 23rd Friday the 23rd meet
Tony Hinchcliffe and Sam Tripoli are
doing the improv and it's about it
you're bad mother [ __ ] any Bravo and
that'd be the timeout Thank You Man
Epstein next time what's going on with
that [ __ ] no one cares about that
dude okay no nobody cares about it oh
yeah because they were all over there
jumpin up and down yeah then
[ __ ] it was puppies hopefully
they find puppies that people will
[ __ ] yeah people can they got video
that dudes guy he the he ain't going on
into the night softly you don't saying
we'll say leave that [ __ ] connected
goes into the night softly
I will be this weekend Friday Lincoln
Theatre in DC it's gun and the Posada in
Atlantic City it's gone - then I got
September 13th Frey
13th and still tickets available in
Dallas [ __ ] tested Texas at the
Majestic Theatre San Antonio's gun and
then there's still tickets available for
the end of the month and a great show at
the Chicago theater and the beautiful
[ __ ] city of Chicago
what's my boy's name is Chicago josh
Josh Pezzini time planet Chicago he'll
pick me up and take me for my [ __ ]
hot like his family's cousin holds the
funk in a good place
yeah so I'm excited about the next two
months oh one more thing I got down you
know most people don't know that I
produce music as well so you can go on
YouTube and listen uh if you're
interested in my music uh it's called my
albums called mix flick of death and
devotion it's for free it's on YouTube
there's about 15 songs on it all with
music videos cut from my favorite movie
so it's uh go check it out Eddie's an
artist assort sorry you bad
[ __ ] I want to thank my man
Eddie Bravo I want to thank the
[ __ ] but most importantly I
want to thank you [ __ ] savages for
always having my back always supporting
the show and always [ __ ] understanding
what we're trying to do here first a
word from our sponsors 23andme listen
we're living in an incredible time you
know me like I said in the beginning of
the show I'm an only child I didn't know
nothing about nothing but with 23andme I
spit in a tube and bang I found out a
ton about myself and the people I came
from DNA testing can tell you a lot
where your ancestors from from and how
much Neanderthal blood you got running
through your veins but did you know you
can also learn about your health with
23andme helps in ancestry service you
can learn how your genes affect you help
get access to 125 personalized health
reports find out if you're predisposed
to type 2 diabetes blood clot or high
cholesterol DNA doesn't lie and ladies
you can also find out if you have the
BRCA gene which can lead to breast
cancer that's a big one the sooner you
know the sooner you could do something
about it so do me a favor 23andme
reports do not diagnose diseases
bribe likelihood of developing a disease
23andme test selected genetic variants
only 23andme calm right now solicit them
and put in slash Church for important
test information and order your health
and ancestry kit today at 23andme calm
slash Church and you can meet your genes
in 125 plus personalized genetic reports
that's number 23 and me doc calm slash
Church find out we go to 23andme dot-com
slash Church the church is also brought
to you by and we'd love to welcome them
Stan's socks listen now when you show a
little ankle you're showing off what
makes you special see whatever you into
they got the design whether it's Star
Wars socks
Harley Davidson socks they even have
Grateful Dead inspired socks every
football team baseball team and
basketball team they got that too it's
not just cool colors and patterns Stan
says everything from running socks ankle
socks hiking socks and premium socks you
can wear at the office Plus Stan's socks
are incredibly comfortable I got them on
right now and I'll tell you what they're
supported they're the most important
socks I've ever owned in my life
that's why Stan's socks are the official
sock of Major League Baseball and those
guys are on their feet 160 games you do
the math and they give back their socks
for Heroes program send socks deployed
military personnel all around the world
I got my icon socks myself and for my
wife and I got a cute little ankle socks
like she likes and even got the flying
Jew some nice blue socks that say good
vibes on them so they remind them what's
important in life all right
long story short Stan's makes a great
gift right now just for the church
family Stan's
has a great offer besides I got you a
New England ones anyway thank you
they just come pretty
soon go to Stan's comm / church and
you'll get a free pair of socks with any
purchase that's right free free pair of
socks whether they purchase when you go
to Stan's comm / Church CH you are CH
this offer is only available for a
limited time so get your socks now at
Stan's comm / Church because if they're
not Stan's that just sucks so do me a
favor throw those old white gym socks
that smell like 10 dead I don't know
what cats away and go to Stan's dot-com
/ Church I wanna thank Stan's
I want to thank 23andme but most
importantly I want to thank you savages
for always having our back it's plain
and simple I'll see you this weekend
Dallas at the Dallas what the [ __ ] am I
saying
I'll see you at the Lincoln Theater
Friday night and I'll see you at the
[ __ ] Borgata I'm only doing one
show so there's a mean greet there's no
misunderstandings like I'm not walking
people get pissed off I love you
[ __ ] I'll see you Monday tip
top [ __ ] Magoo ready to go
shoot the [ __ ] dog let's do this [ __ ]
I love you guys have a great weekend
again the church sends their prayers and
hearts out to the family isn't dating a
no pass all right kick this [ __ ]
mealy
you